how's going Mike what's going down that
Dan what would have to say my name is
Pippa new Montgomery and downtown Logan
that's exactly where I'm going
oh we're gonna take the tram ready to
take it for a spin
oh I spin it on my that's right I said
it I didn't actually said it but I like
to kick stuff like it is kick it
what I hear something well it's happen
after I actually mister what the hell
he's dead
I missed the recording I think it was
before I went to a helot what is this
jump down that's right it's dangerous my
mama always say don't jump down on the
rails that's how I roll oh yeah grab
onto the old black you prepare cook
before you look stylish thanks that
latex
I didn't remember your voice no it's not
like texting alright thank you
anyway nothing really happened we're
just still chasing the criminal from the
price
sorry money Wow Wow
what what the hell was it oh I'm
tripping out checking out some peas best
are your lifesaver it could be
whoa acrobatics on that subway
good right whoa it's not a guy what is
he doing be pad do something hey
well are we stopping wait what are you
doing
it's my defense is immune hey I know
don't make me slap you again blockage I
blocked the foot blockage
stop hitting me ha ha ha ha that's what
you get whoa
if ever in talent I'd like a twirl it's
like skateboarding but
happy day
when he dang
I don't like it
what not back oh no you can do something
na da da da cars and the criminal
escapes
god damn whoa I finished chapter favors
weapon boot why of course I love my
boots I use them weapons all the time
you know if there's a zombie apocalypse
you know it's happening with the boots
all right prepare where are you a lot
I got damn it I lost them so dark and
black I mean I can't
whoa something says me I should not be
going over there something tells me I
should maybe go over here ah the
detection tool tells me hey it's her key
are you then her key it's good to see
you're back and alive
hey it's not good when your blink is it
are you detecting something more dead
birds perhaps oh there you are
all right cool I'll call this one
Hermione
that's right Harry Potter [ __ ] what
are they doing every day it's not
and that's supposed to stand in real
buzz what are you doing there
whoa whoa what the hell was that guy
doing I need to bet better you're good
enough I don't even know your name I
don't even want to know you my name is
kayak
hi you're French - really so what you yo
Gregg will talk you out nope no grab
drag without it hey take the power oh
that's right that's right that's what
you get
I don't need Gregg Gregg was lame what's
your name
Hermione again as a coincidence all
right barrel is blocking the doorway of
course whoa a pump shoot dude I can just
climb up here that cool it's gonna
ladies grab a conduit why would I do
that
I got the shotty power what how do I
open that I never understand so I can
using both hands to hold a shotgun but
it opens anyway it's pretty cool stuff
the shotgun reminds me a lot of it whoa
hey hey hey your mom and even that's not
how you walk that's not how you walk oh
that's right that's how you taste them
by shaking yeah
spasm afterwards love that [ __ ]
especially in that region
good man good fat for you you know what
I don't like you I don't get creepy whoa
creepy as hell
well we touched that don't you dare
that's right got a Taser I taste it or
your mama sitting on I know
the hell is this
and look up to jump down well that makes
sense whoa what what are you doing up
there
how'd he do it well well hey back up
well twice edit price try it tonight
that's right that's right I don't know
why I said but I killed him hey buddy
why was what did he was he doing
no no no we're not going that no one
dare you dare follow me hey hey I can't
talk
hey that walk in circles
what well oh that's right oh oh you
better bring it
come on come on prepare what's he doing
up there you're not a monkey man you're
so lame
so lame barrel whoa cool acrobatics I
like that [ __ ] well not another one hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey like that that's
right what am I doing here
I think I need to go over here and find
a shovel actually so let's do that
no stress I need a shovel there huh we
need to go down here don't you dare
follow me I see you tried that never
works and never what if it works on one
of these days on that hey there your
shallow convinient
what [ __ ] it's that guy whatever dude
don't worry about it baby hey hey you
just took me back why what are you doing
that's all right my quarter is not with
you sir I just want to shovel this [ __ ]
on just like I like
your sister hey what do you do vote
double but Shepherd but quadrant whoa
are you going are you good you can't run
from me [ __ ] you can't run from me you
can't run but you can't hang
Suzie quad but that's bad
hey don't fight back alright hey you
want to kiss you want to kiss oh that's
right
ha ha ha no kiss for you [ __ ] I had but
you alright
what was I doing over here yes shop a
powwow I love you shower oh look what
you'd find Chava
I love you so much we should go on our
honeymoon together maybe get married
first though I don't know maybe it's a
little weird to marry a shovel some
people would say I'd say it's just wrong
dad is going on your shovel
what are you stop being a monkey [ __ ]
tonight beeping [ __ ] all right
what are you doing down there
are you doing that hey hey hey what the
hell man what am i doing
barrels what are you doing there I just
slice you well what's that
oh you're back Jennifer I don't want you
I got shovel II oh my side hey we're
back and I guess I guess we passed the
electricity finger on the ginger ginger
ginger cubes thank you
all right let's see if we thank she's
kind of creepy scary
hold me shovel I'm holding a baby
tighter
and I like you're so slow FBI agent okay
this is where the trend start oh I'm
gonna hunt him down that's right you
better be in here
such subway car for clues that scan this
[ __ ] with my FBI equipment is anything
here any just on the subway that's
disgusting
why would I want is in a subway under
there is sound wait
what is that organic everything glows
bright purple I don't see any organic
[ __ ] where is it seriously maybe outside
no definite not excite oh here we go
what it says oh I got his fingerprints
oh oh that's right FBI [ __ ]
what hey hey
Oh oh he's gay all right
I get a sample with my laser gun that I
have in my back pocket why don't I use
my laser gun more often relax instead
here I guess with shava I did that shava
oh you're gonna oh of course
carefully Mick can't we make out
guys I'm a cat what the hell I wanna
make out with him mmm
like [ __ ] boys back it's not that
handsome you know I don't think he wants
to kiss you okay Mike it Grudge [ __ ]
whoa hey hey hey you got a shovel - we
could be somebody's no no no my shovels
for your [ __ ] yo you trying to offer me
your back a blockage that's right hey
don't block it to me whoa jeez I take me
gladly take you out for dinner sometime
all right this time is open I don't want
to fight that badass it's scary scary
all right Wow
badass black man how are you just don't
wanna fight with you
hey I just said I don't want hey I got a
Taser you know he's trying to dance
before me doesn't wake god damn it I
hate I'm so bad at the combat I just
push me out hey hey hey hey hey he's got
a sledgehammer I better watch it
really thought that would Hecht man
shovel power that's right yeah they look
at that ha ha it's so stupid
there you go you can't run okay
block it block it you can try oh I am so
pissed you are dead but now you don't
[ __ ] say do you seriously shovel I'm
disappointed at you
why was I how will we kill the guy with
the
such hammer in the gas mask
how would like your feedback by Ali
upper back
you're not even pimping luggage blockage
Oh plug it and do it
oh oh you going down you going down yeah
hey hey hey hey you want a kiss
oh you want a kiss all right that's not
a guess
are they doing that's not a woman that's
a weird position today and all right
that's how I roll
[ __ ] yes all right let's go kill some
more hobos shall we hey I got my samples
didn't I
oh I need a sledgehammer there I knew it
come here man I just pick it up it's a
slow thank you
sup sledge she I don't know why you hang
out with that guy he's not cool you know
it's okay okay
that's theirs I don't know if I have a
referendum saying all right whoa Oh he
changed that [ __ ] changed clothes and
he probably took a [ __ ] - god damn it
don't scare me
don't scare don't scare me what what's
going on here
I'm eight am i doing a man defocus
probably on the papers right it's got to
be on the paper no oh oh the map the map
the map of course focus guess this is
his rathole all right it has to be I
found his overalls next to his locker
kick out the fan and climbed through the
[ __ ] really I can do that kick out the
fan whoa whoa hey with someone there
hey oh you're going down sucker you go
hey I'm not going anywhere
well well well
hello sorry about before
I really know what I was doing
I guess oh thank god I need that
and Kevin's alright let's go in here
fire axe hey what do you do now that all
right I need to anything like videos you
enjoyed subscribe comment read today and
I'll see you next video
that's pretty much it stay awesome with
Oh what happened to your friends
happened hey I'm talking to you stop
humping me stop humping me stick out
that's right that shoot sword that's
right that's right that's right that's
right now you blow my deck forever